it's Michelle of lab muffin beauty science chem
PhD cosmetic chemist and sunscreen slapper onner
it's time for Asian sunscreen reviews
some of these I've been asked about a lot so
it's kind of a relief to get these reviews out
these are all Korean and Japanese
sunscreens that aren't approved in
Western countries like Australia except for
the last one which is actually a US sunscreen
what
let's jump straight in with
today's sponsor skin1004
a lot of you have probably heard of them
but if you haven't their centella ampoule
is huge on Korean beauty apps you might
have also seen their zombie masks that
make it look like you've really overdone
it on those TikTok skin care hacks more
recently you might have heard about their
cleansing oil and their water fit Sun serum
they actually have four sunscreens in their range
but this is the one that I hear the
most about and I can understand why
this is a really lightweight chemical sunscreen it
has four of those newer filters that stay more on
the skin's surface so there's less chance
of irritation or potential health impacts
they also absorb UV better so sunscreens can have
a lighter texture while still giving really high
protection this is made by Kolmar who made a
lot of the really popular sunscreens that came
out in the last couple of years and it is a
similar style of product it has that really
beautiful smooth moisturizer texture that's just
beautiful to apply and sits nicely under makeup
it glides on really smoothly like
soft butter on your skin bread
this is even more lightweight than the ones
I've reviewed before like the isntree and
the beauty of joseon so if you found those a
bit heavy then you'll probably like this one
it dries down to feel like almost nothing but
it's still given that hydrating slightly dewy
finish there's no white cast on medium skin tones
and there isn't any added fragrance in terms of
skincare actives it's got centella and a whole
bunch of plant extracts hyaluronic acid glycerin
and niacinamide it's approved as a brightening
and anti-wrinkle functional cosmetic in Korea
alright packaging connoisseur time I love
this pump top you don't really see a lot of
pump tops in Asian sunscreens but I am a huge
fan of them even when they're not twisty tops
the twisty top
it just makes it so easy to apply
a consistent amount and you don't
accidentally just keep on applying less
and less over time without really noticing
also most importantly the pump top
is flat like the tube so it doesn't
actually take up extra space in my
makeup bag it looks round in a lot
of the product photos so I was actually
kind of confused when it came in like a
flat standard Korean sunscreen box I
thought maybe I was thinking of the
wrong product because I'm really unobservant
and that explains a lot of things in my life
I don't know why flat pump tops aren't more
of a thing this just makes so much sense to me
I also tried out the tone brightening tone-up
sunscreen which has the same packaging
tone-up sunscreens are a big thing in Asia they
basically leave a bit of a white cast on your skin
on purpose to give a skin evening and brightening
effect it's like a tinted moisturizer that's a
little bit lighter than your natural skin tone
it's sort of like the Asian equivalent of bronzer
this has mostly the same ingredient
list as the water fit sunscreen with
extra titanium dioxide as well as
some moisturizing ingredients it
feels a little bit heavier and richer
but it's still pretty lightweight
I do not have a good history with tone up
sunscreens a lot of the time they make my skin
look weirdly pink and detached from my neck it's
sort of like I'm having an allergic reaction but
this one is a lot more subtle it actually did make
my skin just look a little bit nicer and smoother
my skin tone looks more even but it's still very
natural with no weird pinkness after it dries down
it takes about 15 minutes though so I spent a
lot of time staring in the mirror going hmmmm
because tone-up sunscreens are essentially
tinted products you do have to apply them
pretty evenly this one is pretty forgiving even
for an unobservant disaster like me sometimes
I do get like a subtle white line here but it
blends out pretty easily without any pilling
so I am more open to tone up sunscreens now
I've been using this when I don't want to go
to the effort of putting on proper makeup
but I want my skin to look a bit nicer and
I have the time to let it settle down and
check for white marks before anyone sees me
the next sunscreen is the Kose Corsair Coast I'm
sorry Suncut UV perfect Essence super waterproof
fun fact this Japanese megacorp that
I can't pronounce owns tarte now
suncut sunscreens are super popular and
I've been recommended this so many times
if you're buying Suncut sunscreens be
really careful because a lot of them
have similar names and packaging so there is
a gel version of this where it's also in a
yellow tube and the only difference
in the name is that essence is gel
this is a fragrance free chemical sunscreen
with mostly newer filters it's designed for
outdoor use as you can probably tell from the
super waterproof thing and the surfing goofy
this is a limited edition tube I have to admit
I partly ordered it because of the goofy if you
want to hook me in just put a face on the
packaging I probably won't be able to throw
it out because it'll just look back at me out of
the bin and I'll just feel really sad and guilty
it's also resistant to sweat and pollution
it has a little bit of a goopy texture and
this nice water burst cooling effect
when you rub it in the cooling comes
from alcohol but I don't think it has that
much because it doesn't really punch you in
the nose like some sunscreens do it doesn't
sting my eyes and I've seen a lot of people
say this doesn't bother their skin as much
as a lot of other sunscreens with alcohol
it's really hydrating with ingredients like
hyaluronic acid plant extracts
royal jelly extract and collagen
this is the one sunscreen in this
video that doesn't have niacinamide
if you're allergic to niacinamide
you must be having the worst time
finding products now so this one
is probably worth checking out
I thought this would be really shiny but
it isn't after it dries down it's actually
quite matte and smooth and lightweight
and not tacky there's no white cast
but unfortunately this does pill up on me it
kind of balls up in little tiny clear sandy
grains and this happened when I applied
it on clean skin and also over products
on the bright side the pilling isn't very
visible but the fact that it is coming off
means that your sunscreen isn't really having that
intact film anymore you're getting less protection
from the reviews I've seen it seems to really
depend on your skin there are lots of people
who say it doesn't pill on them unless they're
using the wrong products underneath I'm guessing
it's because I have oily skin so it's just
having a conscious uncoupling with my skin oil
it probably works better if you have
dry skin I think this is one of those
sunscreens where if it doesn't ball
up on your skin then it's going to
be one of your favorites but I
am not one of kose's chosen ones
here is another lightweight Kolmar sunscreen
it's the Benton airfit UV defense Sun cream
this is pretty much exactly the same as the
beauty of joseon sunscreen they have really
similar ingredient lists and I tested them
side by side I could not tell the difference
between them in terms of texture feel how
they apply and how they look on my skin
the differences are this has a minty scent that
comes from rosemary essential oil and
it looks green coming out of the tube
I originally thought this was giving a cooling
effect because it does say cooling but then I
tried the beauty of joseon one and it felt
exactly the same going on so I think it's
just the water evaporating and maybe a bit of
a psychological effect with that minty smell
I was also hoping that the green color
would help neutralize some of the redness
on my skin but it doesn't I think it's
just too faint to make any difference
the skincare actives in this have a sort of
soothing calming theme it has
centella and licorice extract
as nice as this is it has a bunch of
claims that just make me feel a bit ugh
first off they go on about how
the ingredients are ewg green
grade which means they're rated safe on
the ewg's very arbitrary made up scale
if tone-up sunscreens are like here on
my sus rankings then the ewg is like
yeah I do not like the ewg
they say it's free from octinoxate but
then they don't say what's so bad about
octinoxate they say it's free from silicones
but then it has two silicones right there in
the ingredients list the silicones are
probably a big reason why it feels so
nice and it looks so good under makeup just
please show some respect for the silicones
they say it's blue light protection tested
but they don't give any details about it so
it's been tested but did it do well in the test
like can you share the results with us please
I'm not really seeing anything in the
ingredients list that's an obvious blue
light protector the other similar Kolmar
sunscreens don't have blue light claims
they also have this brand tagline that says
they make "non-chemical" products which is
obviously really silly because everything is
chemicals but especially silly because this
carefully says it has organic UV filters
but then on the website it says it's a
chemical sunscreen I'm guessing they did that
because so many people ask them what organic
means is chemical or physical and they
got sick of answering but then they had
to put chemical on the same website where
they say their products are non-chemical
price wise it's also very similar to
the beauty of joseon sunscreen so I
would just go for that unless
you're like allergic to rice
this sunscreen is a little bit different it
is glow recipe's watermelon
glow niacinamide sunscreen
yes before anyone yells at me glow
recipe is a US brand but they have
Korean American Founders and they
have like a very K Beauty vibe
their products have lightweight textures
they've got a strong focus on hydration
this cute fruit theme they've also
got actives that are very popular
in Korean products like the one that
starts with n and ends in iacinamide
this launch was really exciting to me because
it's an Asian style sunscreen that's actually
approved in the US and stocked in Sephora
so people in the US can actually go and try
the sunscreen before buying it and not have to
wait for shipping or worry about fake products
the downside of a US sunscreen is that their
sunscreen ingredient options
are a bit "needs improvement"
so it was really great to see glow
recipe take on this challenge of
trying to make a US approved sunscreen
that actually feels nice and lightweight
I really really wanted to like this
but it did the one thing that is like
a complete deal breaker for me it
pilled up on my skin pretty badly
and the pilling was very visible
it was very like white and gray
this sunscreen does not pill
on everyone there are lots of
people who love this but it does seem
to pill up on a good portion of people
I tried so hard to make this work
I tried it on bare skin right after
washing I tried it after 15 minutes after
an hour then I saw on TikTok someone say
that it worked on their skin after they
moisturized it really well so I tried it
over six different products with really
different formulas and it didn't work
so by that point I was pretty
depressed and I gave up
every time I tried it it was fine
when I first put it on but then
after it's set after maybe about
five ten minutes if I even brushed
against it then it would pill and you
could really really see those pills
I don't know if it's like my skin or the
humidity here in Sydney or just some other curse
I'm sure there's some product out
there that would stop this from
pilling on me but I have not found
it and I am too sad to keep going
I'm also the sort of person who puts on
makeup right before leaving the house so if
a sunscreen pills a lot then it is probably
not going to work with my extreme lifestyle
otherwise this is pretty nice it's not really
as lightweight as the Asian sunscreens I've
been trying but considering that it does only
use US filters I think they did really well
there was some white cast but not as much as
I expected for an untinted sunscreen with 12%
zinc oxide it is a bit shiny but dewy skin is
sort of part of glow recipe's brand and it is
actually quite hydrating which is pretty
impressive again there is 12% zinc in this
I love that they did this but I would
recommend trying a sample on your own
skin before buying the full tube because who it
pills on seems to be a bit all over the place
I hope you enjoyed this let me know what else
you want me to try click the like and subscribe
to tell YouTube you want to watch more of my
videos and more reviews are popping up around me